المترجم: Samir Tal'at
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
أريد من كل منكم أن يفكر في طفولته
ما هو أكثر ما كان يشغلكم حينها؟
بالنسبة لي، ما كان يشغلني هي فكرة واحدة
إنني لا أريد ان أعيش حياة اعتيادية
مثل أي شخص أخر
كنت أريد أن افعل شيئا مميزاً
لم يفعله أحد من قبل
لكنى لم أعلم ماذا
و هكذا بدأت أن أفكر
أردت ان أجعل أبي و أمي فخورين بي
أردت أن أكون شيئاً مهماً
شخصاً مميزاً للغاية
و بدأت أن أفكر كطفل
و قلت : ما الذي يمكنني ان افعله لأكون
مصدر للفخر، ليس لأهلي فقط لكن للعالم أجمع
فكرت و قلت لنفسي : حسناً، إن أبي مدرس
و أمي مدرسة ايضاً
و أنا كنت أعلم إننى لا أريد أن اكون مدرساً
و هو ما أصبحت عليه اليوم
لكني قلت لنفسي : حسناً، أنا متأكد من أن
هناك شيء ما أستطيع أن أفعله
ليجعل مني ذلك الشخص المميز
و في يوم ما جائتني الفكرة
و قد كانت اللغة العربية
لقد نشأت في أمريكا، في نيو جيرسي
في مكان حيث آمن الناس
أنه من المستحيل لأمريكي أن يتعلم
اللغة العربية كما يتعلمها العرب
والدي يتحدث العربية جيداً بالفعل، و لكن
عندما يتحدث يدرك الناس أنه ليس بعربي
يدرك الناس أنه أجنبي تعلم اللغة العربية
و كان والدي دائماً يخبرني
أمير، أريد منك أن تكون أفضل مني
في كل شيء في الحياة
أريد منك أن تكون الشخص الذي لم
أستطيع أن أكون عليه
و أنا لم أعلم ما الذي يجب علي أن أفعله
لأكون أفضل من والدي
و لكن في النهاية بدأت أفكر في الأمر
و قلت : إنها اللغة العربية
سوف أثبت لنفسي أنني أستطيع أن أتعلمها
مثل أي شخص أخر
و بدأت أن أمل، بدأت أن أحلم
و لكن ليس هناك أي طريقة أحقق بها هذا الحلم
و أصبح حلمى في هذا الوقت هو أن أدرس
مع أبي الذى كان يتقن اللغة العربية
و عندما حان الوقت لألتحق بفصله
كانت المدرسة قد أغلقت، و قد أصبت بالأحباط
أعتاد والدي أن يسافر كل صيف لبلد عربي ما
ليصقل مهارته باللغة العربية
و كنت أتوسل إليه كل عام
و كنت أقول له : خذني معك
و كان يقول لي : لا، في المرة القادمة
و من ثم نتحدث عن كيف يجب حياتي أن تكون
و كان كل هذا عندما كان عمري
حينها بين الخامسة والسابعة
و عندما كنت بسن السابعة
كان والدي مسافراً إلى مصر
و قلت له : خذني معك
مرة أخرى قال : لا، سوف أخذك العام القادم
فقلت له : لقد قلت ذلك في العام السابق
فقال : إذاً حسناً
إذا حصلت على درجات جيدة هذا العام
سوف أخذك معي
و النتيجة، أنتهى الحال بي
في قائمة أفضل 100 طالب في الولاية
و قد كان نجاحاً عظيماً لي
و قد أتيت الى مصر بالفعل و مكثت
لثلاثة اشهر و رجعت بعدها
و لكني تذوقت كيف يبدو الحال
عندما أتبع حلمي، أردت المزيد!
أصبحت مهووساً بأن أحصل على
فرصة لأسافر مرة أخرى لأدرس
و بدأت أقول أنني لو حصلت على الفرصة
سأثبت بأن الجميع كانوا مخطئين
و ذات يوم عندما كنت بعمر العاشرة
ناداني والدي وقال لي أريد أن أتحدث معك
جلسنا لنتحدث و قال لي : هل تتذكر
عندما سافرت إلى مصر منذ ثلاثة أعوام؟
أتحب أن تسافر إلى هناك مرة أخرى
و تبقى هناك لتدرس؟
فقلت له : نعم!
ثم قال لي : لكن
أنا لن أذهب معك
والدتك لن تذهب معك
و أخوتك سيظلون هنا
كل أصدقائك و عائلتك سوف يظلون هنا
هل أنت واثق أنك تريد الذهاب؟
قلت : نعم!
هل تتفهم أنك من الممكن أن تموت هناك
و لن أكون موجوداً من أجلك
و ربما نموت نحن هنا و لن تكون موجوداً
من أجلنا، هل أنت واثق من هذا؟
والدي شخص عملي للغاية
و كان يريد أن يتأكد أنني بعد أن أسافر
لن أتصل بعد أسبوع لأقول
أريد أن أعود للمنزل
هو لم يكن متأكداً حينها
و لكن في هذا الوقت
رأيت حلمي بين يدي
و لذلك كل أعتراض كان يذكره
كان كأنه يقول
و هكذا سافرت
وصلت إلى مطار الاسكندرية،21 يناير 2000
و كان المكان ممتلىء بالقطط و الكلاب
خرجت من المطار، و أوقفت سيارة اجرة
حاول السائق أن يكون ودوداً معي
و أن يتحدث معي
و لكنه لا يعلم أي كلمة انجليزية
و أنا لا اعلم أي كلمة عربية
و كان يحاول أن يسألني
ما أسمي باللكنة المصرية
و أنا لم ادرس ذلك في المدرسة
و أخذ يحاول أن يستخدم لغة جسده
ليجعلني افهم و لكن بلا جدوى
ربما يحاول أن يقول ما هو أسمي
فقلت له : امير
و ثم سألني كم عمري، و لم أفهم ذلك ايضاً
و كان يحاول أن يستعمل الانجليزية ليخبرني
أننى لا أستطيع أن أدفع ثمن الأجرة
لكنه بدى كأنه يسألني عن البيض
فقلت : بيض؟ انا لست دجاجة
و بعد كثير من لغة الجسد و كثير من سوء
التفاهم بيننا اخبرته : عشرة سنوات
و كانت هذه بدايتي
نزلت من التاكسي إلى مكان اقامتي
و كانت السماء تمطر، و كان علي ان
اسير في الطين الذي وصل الى هنا
فقلت لنفسي
ما الذي كنت أفكر فيه!
و بدأت أن أعتني بشئون نفسي
أحدهم ساعدني أن أسجل في المدرسة
و لكنه لم يخبرني أنها كانت حضانه!
و هكذا فقد أرسلت إلى مدرسة مع اطفال
بعمر الثانية والثالثة و أنا كنت في العاشرة
و كنت أجلس في كرسي صغير جداً
شعرت باحراج شديد
و لكنني قلت لنفسي : أتعلم ماذا يا امير
هؤلاء الاطفال يتحدثون العربية على عكسك
عليك أن تعطيهم بعض الأحترام
كنت أنتهي من الحضانة وأذهب إلى أحد الجيران
الذى كان يتعلم دروس في المرحلة الابتدائية
كنت أخذ دروساً للصف الأول، الصف الثاني،
الصف الثالث والصف الرابع، واحداً تلو الأخر
كنت أفعل ذلك من الثامنة صباحاً
و حتى الرابعة عصراً
ثم أعود للمنزل لأتناول الطعام، أغير ملابسي
و أخرج لحضور دروس القرآن و الصف الخامس
ظللت أفعل ذلك كل يوم
من مارس 2000 حتى اغسطس 2000
بعدها ذهبت إلى القاهرة، لأختبر مهاراتي
و أرى إلى أي حد سوف أصل
و للمفاجأة أنني نجحت أن ألتحق بالازهر في
الصف السادس وهو ما كان مفاجأة عظيمة لي
و بدأت أدرس و بدأت اطور من نفسي
و بدأت أن أشعر اخيراً بأن حلمي يقترب مني
بدأت أن أشعر اخيراً بأنني أستطيع أن
أحقق حلمي
و بعد القليل من الوقت
وجدت بأنني أستطيع التحدث بالعربية
وجدت بأنه لا يقف أمامي شيئاً
إذا أردت شيئاً فليس بيني
و بين هذا الشيء إلا مجهودي
لكننى أعيش بين الناس غريب
أتحدث بالعربية نعم لكني مازلت غريبا
كلما أذهب إلى مكان ينظرون إلى كأنني غريب
و أنا لا أحب أن أكون غريباً
أحب أن أكون مثل جميع الناس
لا فرق بين أمريكي و عربي باللغة
كلنا واحد، كلنا أخوة
فأردت أن تزال هذه التفرقة
و أردت أن أعيش مع الناس، مثل الناس
لكننى كلما أفكر في شيء أسمع صوت أبي
الذى أوقفني قبل أن أسافر فى المطار
و قال لي :
يا بنى، إنك ستسافر إلى مصر
و إن أستطعت ألا تتعلم العامية فلا تتعلمها
لأنها ليست لغة
لكني قررت أن أعصي أوامر أبي
بعد أن مررت ببعض الظروف و بعض الأحوال
أولها حين كنت في المدرسة في يوم
و كان الجو بارداً، فأردت أن أغلق النافذة
فقلت للمدرس، مدرس النحو
الذي يعلمنى العربية
قلت له : يا أستاذ سأقوم لأغلق النافذة
فقال : أيه!
فقلت : سأقوم لأغلق النافذة
فقال : هاه!
فقلت : حاقوم أقفل الشباك
موقف أخر، كنت ذاهباً إلى المكتبة في يوم
فأردت أن أركب تاكسي
فأوقفت التاكسي ثم قلت : المكتبة من فضلك
فقال : أركب
فجعل يتحدث معي و أتحدث معه
ثم حين وصلت قلت له : أنزلني ها هنا من فضلك
ثم قلت له : كم تريد؟
فقال : خمسون دولاراً
فقلت له : خمسين عفريت يركبوك
فأنا كان لازم أن أنا أتغير
كان لازم أتحدى نفسي مرة بعد مرة
عشان أوصل لأهدافي و طموحاتي
ممكن حد منكم يكون قاعد و يقول :
طيب يا أمير، و ظروفك مش زى ظروفنا
صح، عندكم حق، ظروفي مش زى ظروفكم
أنا جيت مصر و عشت بعيد عن أهلي سنين طويلة
أنا قعدت 11 سنة مشفش وش أمي
قعدت سنين مسمعش صوتها
قعدت سنين مشفش أي حد من أهلي
و في نفس الوقت أنا أضطريت أشتغل
و أنا عندي 12 سنة
ليه؟ لأن أهلي مش أغنياء
عندهم ظروف زي ما عندكم هنا ظروف
فأنا أشتغلت حاجات كتيرة جداً
من نجارة لسباكة لفحت، كل حاجة في البناء
أشتغلت في الترجمة، أشتغلت
مع أطباء، مع مهندسين
كل حاجة، ليه؟ علشان أنا عايز أحقق
أهدافي، عايز أحقق طموحاتي
فأيه اللى يخلينا أحنا نقف
ورا أحلامنا و طموحاتنا
و منسعاش وراها و أننا نستسلم للأمر الواقع
لا بالعكس، لازم أنت تتحدى كل الناس
أنا أنهرده لما برجع أمريكا و أشوف الناس
قالوا عليا و على أبويا و على أمي مجانين
أنهم سابوني أسافر ورا حلمي، قالوا أبويا
قاسي القلب، أمي معندهاش دم
عشان سايبه أبنها يسافر بعيد عنها
حتى و أنا صغير قعدت أفكر في كلامهم
أنتوا بتقولوا مستحيل أن واحد أمريكي
يتعلم العربية زى العرب و في
المدرسة بتقولولي أن ربنا القدير
مستحيل، قدير، مستحيل، قدير، فيه حد كذاب
أكيد مش ربنا
فاللي عايز أسئله اليوم
اللي عايز أسئله اليوم :
مين هنا عنده حلم جواه؟
طيب حلمك اللي جواك ده
اللي جواك ده اللي أنت بتسعى وراه
أو مبتسعاش
اللي أنت ناسيه
أو بتدي كل مجهودك عشان تحققه
تفتكر أن ربنا أدهولك عشان يعذبك بيه؟
ولا أدهولك عشان انت تقوم
و تجاهد عشان تحققه
شكراً!